depuis dix ans je pars le matin et je
prends des photos de montréal je dois
avoir beau mot 15 à 25 mille photos sur
internet de morale et combien de cartes
sim fort ici il doit avoir minimum 600
ou 700 photos l'idée de maisonneuve
c'était extraordinaire on voulait faire
les champs elysées de mon frère c'était
vraiment quelque chose qui se voulait
une belle ville la fermière est encore à
tout une valeur symbolique
c'est bizarre parce que dans la ville la
plus riche qui se voulait la plus riche
on a rendu hommage à la ruralité c'est
ça que j'aime ici le bon côtoie il l'est
pour quelqu'un qui aime se nourrir bien
sens bien s'alimenter le quartier
maintenant extraordinaire
en prennent un coup
ben oui cette ia c'est ici qu'il plaisir
mais aussi pour ses virulentes de
similitude de quartier on est spécialisé
vraiment en produits locaux
ici on sent qu'on à béthencourt magasin
général de cartier qu'on voulait faire
revivre d'ailleurs à l'entrée il ya un
petit truc sur la bolduc
elle habitait à 2 320 d'ici donc on se
souvient que dans le quartier a eu une
histoire industrielle il ya un renouveau
ce une énergie de vivre son quartier qui
nous ont fait vivre car c'est dans la
boutique histoire puis le québec aussi
peu comme le postier au bureau de poste
jadis les gens se ramasser sur le parvis
de l'église son bureau de poste pour
parler des homologues ont fait la même
chose on parle avec les gentils devenu
un art de vivre de remarcher son
quartier de redécouvrir de levine
finalement donc ici on arrive à l'étape
importante
on va les biscuits et des bonbons
chocolats des noms avant 80 % de la
clientèle
c'est la clientèle locale mais on l'a
aussi 20% de la clientèle clientèle de
destination gouvernement des usa union
2000 on avait eu un feu n'avait été
fermé pour trois quatre mois et à la
connerie ou weill des clients dit les
détails sur les ovnis rester un biscuit
dans notre boîte à biscuits ont les
accélérer ce seraient les classes inouïe
au moins une trentaine de poètes dans le
quartier et puis cap hier lundi vers la
rivière qui est directeur a eu l'idée de
ce projet là il ya fait un appel aux
gens aux gens de la rue opère un des
animateurs du quartier est aussi à des
gens de la maison de la culture
c'est là que l'immunité de la voir une
bêta police
je crains rien c'est juste un pli c'est
un petit plus qui dit rien une poupe se
demande dans le front comment ça finira
au rien de bien grave ce petit pli je ne
connais pas
qu'est ce que ça change et
pour avoir des poèmes qui poussent sur
les trottoirs les gens se parlent plus
il sans plus moi c'est l'impression que
ça me donne 10 dames 1 09 pourquoi pas
ça mais vous vous aimez les sorties il
ya tellement de méchantes choses qui se
passent haut la terre mais je me dis
comme ça c'est une chose que c'est un
beau projet qu'est le gabon peut se
mettre davantage
mais continuons de le voir
la mise